hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
week out in la i got to visit a little
nike gathering where kobe unveiled his
latest shoot the kobe 11. and this is a
pretty special one to him it's the last
shoe he'll release during his active
career and it's the last one he'll wear
on the court so i got to talk with him
about it a little bit about tech a
little bit about the shoe and beyond
enjoy during the busy regular season and
all the basketball and all the training
all you got all the stuff you guys are
doing how much
tech smartphones cameras whatever do you
get to follow i know roy is actually
like pretty into tech shout out to roy
if he's watching what kind of stuff you
get to see
well i mean from a tech perspective you
know i've i've kind of tried to dabble
into it a little bit but i found myself
not being extremely passionate about it
unless it's centered around sports
right and things that involve
health
training
things of that sort
but overall i wouldn't describe myself
as a very tech savvy person my question
related to that since we're carrying
smartphones all the time now yeah
entering the league like what kind of
tech did you carry did you like listen
to music for a game have that kind of
stuff going on yeah i mean i you know it
was back in the day let's see when i
first came in the league i had a phone
that was probably about the size
of
my head yeah you know what i mean and
then we kind of graduated to having
sidekicks and things like that and i
remember having walkman players and cd
players my kids have no idea yeah what a
cd player is let alone a walkman it was
like wait you had to rewind what
yeah wait when that song was over you
had to flip it over and like use the
other side of the tape yeah yeah yeah so
you know um when i first came in lee
the world was such a different place
than it is now in terms of connecting
people and being able to follow and
things of that sort yeah that's the
other thing is the internet lets you
connect to your teammates your fans all
kinds of stuff like that
um but it also gives you a great
advantage by the way because back then
when i came to league i had to do a lot
of research myself which involved going
and actually getting books on the
history of the game and other players
and things like that but nowadays i mean
you're a click away from finding out
make scouting easier it makes extremely
easier yeah right and so you know as a
as a culture we should actually be much
smarter yeah yeah versus becoming
dumber right because of the crutch of
technology exactly no i agree completely
so get into the shoe uh being interested
in the tech of the shoe i know you have
a big hand in the design how you put it
together
how much like how closely you get to
work with the designer specifically on
the tech and what's going into the shoe
extremely close yeah you know because
the shoe is always an extension of the
athlete in this case you know for you
know the years i've been with nike it's
an extension of myself right so the shoe
must
um
must be something that's going to help
me perform better yeah and if it doesn't
do that we're not going to create the
shoe i heard a story earlier today about
soccer and soccer shoes and having a
low-cut shoe i play a sport called
ultimate frisbee
may or may not have heard of it but a
lot of us wear soccer cleats to play so
that kind of struck a vibe with me
tell me about how this kind of stuff
translates from
the soccer pitch or cleats or low-cut
cleats to the basketball court sure so
growing up i played a lot of soccer yeah
and so i've always been a big fan of the
sport and so i remember watching the
game on tv as a champions league match
and saying man they put a lot of torque
on their ankles actually more than we do
yeah
why can't i create a low basketball shoe
doesn't make any sense so then i started
doing a little bit more research and
started kind of figuring out how the
ankle actually benefits from being able
to move
freely into spring
yeah so you put less stress on your knee
joints and things of that nature i said
you know we're gonna do a low-cut shoe
um but now we have to really lock in the
hill yeah right because you can't have
the hill sliding around because it puts
puts the athlete in jeopardy gives them
more uh makes it more susceptible to
ankle sprains and things like that you
know you have to make sure that the
forefoot is really flexible right you
have to make sure you're strengthening
in areas that are extremely important
where in the height
shoe you can kind of get away with right
those things yeah i feel like a lot of
ultimate players you either get a low
cut cleat i wear a soccer cleat but then
you get like something for the ankle in
addition right or you'll sacrifice
weight
and get
more on the ankle right we don't
compromise exactly so this is this is
the flyknit material this is a big part
of the weight savings tell me about like
like details you had a hand in to design
this kind of stuff yeah so what we did
with the with the 11 is we actually
improved the flyknit so we made the
flyknit sturdier made it stronger
um and and then we've actually combined
technology so we've combined uh some
free technology we've combined some of
the zoom and lunar technology with been
some of the staples with some of my
other shoes
but they normally behave in isolation
right they normally don't communicate
with each other so it's been our
challenge to try to figure out how to
create kind of this marriage between the
technologies awesome best of luck in
getting more of that tech savvy stuff
going i hope you get on top of the game
i would recommend a smartphone right now
but i wouldn't know what to say because
i don't know what kind of usage you have
i'm a big i'm a big iphone guy i mean
you know i'm a big iphone guy okay fair
so i think that's pretty much it thanks
for being a part of this i appreciate
the time uh and hopefully we get to do
it again thank you awesome